[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTIAN ERICKSEN: The
Android development Immersive
is a full-time course.
It's a class that takes people
with little or no experience
coding and aims to have them
be full-on Android Developers.
SCOTT KIRKPATRICK: Android
is the wave of the future.
Creating the next generation
of Android developers
is so critical to
our mission, it's
so critical to our
global community.
It's changing the world, and
we need to be a big part of it.
JAKE SCHWARTZ: Android is one
of the fastest growing platforms
in the world, with an
incredible need for developers
to serve the demand
that there is out there
and to build applications
on the Android platform.
And so we're really
excited to sort
of empower both the developer
community as well as students
CHRISTOPHER SHUM:
Class experience
has been really great.
We're all from
different backgrounds,
but we all have
the same motivation
for doing this program.
JAMES DAVIS: You
have an instructor
that will be there to help you
out with whatever you need.
You'll have students that'll
be around you that you
can feed off of.
We're constantly teaching
each other, constantly
learning from each other.
DREW MAHRT: We're
building our lesson plans.
We worked with Google
to get an idea of what
they thought was necessary
for an Android developer
to be successful.
JAKE SCHWARTZ:
Partnering with Google
is always a very exciting thing.
They clearly see the importance
of supporting the developer
community through
efforts like this.
CHRISTOPHER SHUM:
It's going to be
exciting to go to Google's
office in New York, so, yeah.
Can't wait.
SARAH CLARK: The
goal of the program
is to build people
who are really
ready to get professional work
as Android developers working
at some at the top
companies in the country.
And we've had Google
guest speakers dial in
and you can tell
they're doing the work.
They're thinking about it.
MALE SPEAKER: We were there
just this last weekend.
MALE SPEAKER: My day
is going amazing.
MALE SPEAKER: Hit stop.
ANNA LINDOW: Our
full-time courses
are intense, exhilarating,
transformative, probably
at times a little bit
overwhelming, but ultimately,
just life changing.
DREW MAHRT: The student
progress has been amazing.
They came from no
experience to being
able to make Android apps that
are ready for the Play Store.
And seeing the projects
they've been doing lately,
really, they are ready to
jump into the industry.
RASHAD CURETON: They
took you from 0 to 100
and created a well-rounded
developer in all of us.
ANNA LINDOW: We believe
that mobile development
is a skill set that is
deeply in demand today.
There are not enough mobile
developers in the world
and we're pleased to be
able to help create more.
SARAH CLARK: I was really
impressed with General Assembly
and how they've thought through
the instructional process
and how it works
for their students.
This is not one of those
where somebody goes home
and they never use it again.
These are people that
are really thinking
about it and passionate
and building apps
and as someone who teaches,
that's, like, our dream.
ANNA LINDOW:
Completing ADI, we hope
and we know that
this will happen.
That our students
will zealously enter
into jobs as Android
developers, making stuff,
building apps they're proud
of, and, ultimately, doing work
they love.
[MUSIC PLAYING]